on this friday night a carefully
choreographed service for the queen
the message to the monarch who couldn't
be there but we are so glad
that you are still in the saddle and the
guests who did show up
plus the complex relationship between
indigenous peoples in canada and the
crown
100 days of russia's war in ukraine
an inside look at the horror one village
has endured and the ontario premier wins
a second majority
the consequences for doug ford's
competitors
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight from london
[Music]
we are overlooking the tower of london
tonight not far from here is saint
paul's cathedral you can see the dome of
it off in the distance there it was
filled today with royalty politicians
and special guests a thank you to the
queen for her 70 years of service
good evening and thanks for joining us
the queen was absent from that service
staying home after suffering discomfort
yesterday and she watched it on tv
instead it was announced today she'll
also miss a horse racing derby tomorrow
but the couple who have quit royal
duties and left the uk to live in the
u.s did make an appearance we have
complete coverage tonight beginning with
crystal gomezy
[Music]
with church bell's tolling a rare sight
in royal life the duke and duchess of
sussex reappearing in public in london
just as impossible to overlook the
absence of the queen herself from
friday's platinum jubilee commemorations
what do you think of the fact that her
majesty isn't here today oh it's a shame
isn't it it's a shame that she can't be
here but we appreciate why so um yeah
we'll just watch her on the television
and she can watch everybody on the
television as well so she gets joy from
actually watching this as well because
it is you know this is just thank her
for her her duty to the country
with 70 years on the throne queen
elizabeth is the longest serving british
monarch and the third longest serving
monarch in world history your majesty
the thanksgiving service at st paul's
cathedral was the spiritual center of
the platinum jubilee festivities the
queen is well known for her deeply
religious convictions
when sharing her decision to not attend
the event the palace said it came with
great reluctance
we are sorry that you're not here with
this morning
but we are so glad
that you are still in the saddle
and we are glad
that there is still
more to come
thank you for staying the course the
queen is 96 and experienced discomfort
after a long day of celebrations
thursday she manages mobility issues
often walking with a cane these days and
spent one night in hospital last october
the palace routinely says she is in good
health but does need time to recharge
the way the queen is at the moment brain
is razor sharp few mobility issues but
no sort of overt sickness
given her mobility issues it's possible
that the 24 steps of saint paul's
cathedral not including the two landings
may have played a role in the queen
deciding not to attend the service she
will also not be attending the epsom
darby on saturday a beloved event for
her and one she has rarely missed over
the decades
donna
all right crystal gomezing at st paul's
cathedral thanks well services like the
one today are carefully choreographed
harry and megan arrived before prince
william and prince charles and took
their seats
sitting across the aisle and a few rows
back from harry's brother and father
and they were not seen interacting with
them but they may have done so in
private they would not have been there
though had it not been approved by the
queen
she wants to see her family together we
know that we are now entering the
queen's twilight years i think
everything we're seeing is that the
queen wants all those loose ends tied up
she wants to go knowing that everything
is in check knowing that her
grandchildren are at least on talking
terms
a little later we'll get more insight
into the queen and how she manages
challenges from an author who's just
written a biography of her
to ukraine now it has been 100 days
since russian forces invaded ukraine's
president sent a familiar message today
to his people
ukraine
vladimir zelinsky saying ukrainians have
done what seemed impossible stopping
russia from taking over the country but
tens of thousands of lives have been
lost millions have fled their homes and
there's no end in sight jeff semple went
to one ukrainian village that is a
microcosm of what ukraine has endured
this ukrainian farming village of
vilhevka sits just 30 kilometers from
the russian border so when russia
invaded this was one of the first places
to be hit
gennady novikova says he was out buying
milk when the shelling started he rushed
home to find a russian rocket crashed
into his backyard a fragment flew
through this window and struck his
mother a russian-born farmworker in the
head
by the time i found her she was already
dead he says novikova wanted his mother
to have a proper burial so he gathered
some colleagues from the farm where she
worked to bring her body to the cemetery
but as they lowered her into the grave
another russian rocket hit killing two
young men members of the burial party
it's a horror says this farmer who
attended the burial
no one thought this could happen in a
cemetery russian forces quickly took
control of the village on route to
harkev ukraine's second largest city
olena bobrisheva watched as a large
convoy of russian vehicles rolled down
her street
we were so scared she says we hid in the
bathroom we didn't leave the house for
weeks the russians took down the
village's ukrainian flag and knocked on
doors looking for food and warm clothing
but otherwise she says the soldiers
mostly kept to themselves sheltering in
this school
after about a month under occupation the
ukrainians pushed back ukraine's
military recorded this video as it
launched an all-out assault on the
school to take back the village
when the dust settled the ukrainians had
won
but this is what was left this is
ukrainian street in the heart of the
village and it appears to have been the
site of a major battle we're seeing
massive craters from rockets anti-tank
weapons and bullets every single house
on this street except one has been
completely destroyed residents emerged
to find vilhevka in ruins and even in
retreat the russian shelling didn't stop
nadia cutler's 32 year old son alexi was
walking to the bus station in late april
to collect aid when he was killed by a
russian rocket
afraid of the cemetery she buried him in
the backyard
he has two young daughters our family
was happy she says now i can't even eat
i can't go on korean
now two months since vilhevka was
liberated there's still no electricity
gas or water its remaining residents
line up for donations of food trying to
rebuild and salvage their crops
even as artillery thunders not far away
jeff semple global news in vilhevka
ukraine
tomorrow jeff hosts a global news
special 100 days in ukraine it airs at 8
30 on global television
in ontario doug ford is starting a
second term with a majority government
voter turnout though was at an historic
low the majority of ontarians didn't
cast a ballot for anyone eric sorenson
on ford's big win and voter apathy
what a night
and what a result
a result so dominating that both major
opposition leaders quit on the spot it's
time for me to pass the torch i informed
our party president of my decision to
step down doug ford led the biggest
province through the worst of the
pandemic coming out of it ontario voters
had little appetite for change the
campaign so lackluster a record number
of voters just stayed home the public
this time around did not feel there was
going to be a change in government and
did not and enough of them did not feel
that there was a need to change the
government really good to see him ford
also transformed as a politician over
the last four years becoming a more
moderate conservative you grow into the
position he discovered that getting
along with the federal liberal
government could work at least in
ontario i'm not big into these political
stripes i don't care if you're from the
red blue green orange party i'm going to
take care of you we're going to work
hard and create jobs ford found success
wooing the same swing voters in the
greater toronto area who had helped the
trudeau liberals win last fall's federal
election you've got to appeal to that
that you know middle class voter not be
too scary by showing that you can work
well together and that you're a moderate
does play to these swing ridings for the
two opposition parties a crossroads in
need of new leadership and faced with
the perpetual predicament progressive
parties splitting a majority of votes
cast and paving the way for the ontario
conservatives to win a massive victory
should this result spurs some discussion
for the like-minded to stop undercutting
each other they might want to consider
joining forces there's nothing
preventing a new party on the left
emerging that combines the values and
ideas of the liberals of the ndp the ndp
has long promoted proportional
representation to better reflect the
public's voting preference that of
course could reduce the number of
conservative seats so don't expect any
help from doug ford with that idea i
think this system has worked for over
100 some odd years eric sorensen global
news toronto
one year ago today the federal
government unveiled its plan to address
violence towards indigenous women and
girls and promised transformative change
as dan spector reports 12 months later
many indigenous leaders and advocates
are disappointed at the lack of progress
[Music]
it was supposed to be a road map for the
way forward a national action plan to
end violence against indigenous women
born out of the national inquiry into
missing and murdered indigenous women
and girls final reports the government
also releasing what it called a federal
pathway promising transformative change
i made a promise
that we would confront those truths but
one year later advocates say not nearly
enough has been done to stop with the
inquiry's final report called a genocide
this is a national shame and it is also
dangerous the chair of the national
family and survivors circle denouncing
what she calls a lack of progress and
accountability we've yet to see the
adoption of clear timelines and
measurable outcomes that are necessary
to achieve transformative change
that will keep indigenous women girls
and 2s lgbtqia
plus people safe indigenous
organizations say though the government
has promised billions in funding the
money has not yet been accounted for
while some funding is being done here
and there it almost seems like it's a
patchwork
the native women's association of canada
walked away from participating in the
action plan over concerns about the
process this has not been a priority for
the government some of the most
significant steps that needed to be
taken including
establishing an oversight body we
haven't seen that movement there the
government released its own progress
report friday pointing to recent
advances in supporting indigenous
culture safety security and justice
things aren't moving fast enough
but they are moving forward but to
people on the ground more is needed than
pledges and promises the reason this is
important is
for the future
we don't want any more children
going missing brian gallagher's daughter
has been missing for 18 months a man was
charged in connection with her
disappearance this week his pleas for
change are deeply personal there are so
many families out there suffering the
same realities
gallagher's other daughter is walking
across canada to raise awareness right
now the family says until there is
meaningful change actions to build
awareness are still necessary dan
specter global news montreal
there is support available if you need
it the number is toll-free 24 hours a
day 1-844-413-6649
new revelations about the deadly january
6th attack on the u.s capitol coming up
what former u.s vice president mike
pence was warned about the day before
there is more sinister information
emerging tonight at the attempted
insurrection on the u.s capitol in
washington on january 6 2021 we know
when the mob attacked some people were
heard shouting hang mike pants and a
gallows was set up outside well now
information is emerging staff of the
former vice president warned the secret
service former president donald trump
might turn on pence our washington
bureau chief jackson proskow is
following this tonight jackson
donna the new york times reports that on
january 5th the day before the attack
the chief of staff to then vice
president mike pence warned the secret
service that president trump was going
to publicly turn against his vp and that
could pose a security risk the warning
of course turned out to be right the
next day the mob stormed the capitol and
chanted hang mike pence after he refused
to block certification of joe biden's
victory now the other significant
development is the arrest of peter
navarro he's the former trump advisor
who was indicted for contempt of
congress because he has refused to
cooperate with the committee
investigating the events of january 6.
navarro is the second trump adviser
indicted for defying subpoenas two other
trump allies have been referred for
prosecution and all of this sets the
stage for a contentious week ahead the
first televised hearings into january 6
begin next week in prime time and the
committee has already promised to
release previously unseen evidence about
trump's attempts to subvert democracy
donna
jackson crossco in washington thanks
jackson
the crown and canada's indigenous
peoples ahead their demands for
reparations instead of celebrations
we're back from london in a moment
welcome back to london over her 70-year
reign the queen has gained respect and
affection for indigenous peoples in
canada who have lived on the land long
before it was settled by europeans the
relationship with the crown is complex
as abigail beeman reports the jubilee is
sparking renewed questions about the
monarchy's role in reconciliation
the indigenous relationship with the
british crown dates back more than a
century before canada's confederation
when the first land treaties were signed
we have a very special relationship with
the monarchy because of that
relationship through treaty long as the
river flows and the sun shines
over 70 years on the throne and on each
visit to canada queen elizabeth paid
special focus to the relationship with
indigenous communities including travel
to remote areas during eras when the
journey was more complex than it is
today but while there has always been
some excitement surrounding visits and
frequently even warmth for the monarchy
among many indigenous communities for
countless others there's also profound
disappointment and distrust i'm so angry
my anger is so deep for beverly jacobs a
mohawk woman from six nations 70 years
on the throne is nothing to celebrate
she calls it seven decades of what
amounts to silence on missing and
murdered indigenous women residential
schools and treaty violations to try to
erase us as a people
you know they've never taken
responsibility for that
some find hope in the appointment of
canada's first indigenous governor
general mary simon
i am sorry
i am more sorry than i can say others in
the recent apology for residential
schools from the archbishop of
canterbury the spiritual head of the
church of england
there are formal calls for the queen to
apologize to most recently from the
afn's national chief directly to prince
charles during last month's royal visit
but there are a multitude of
perspectives i think that's a waste of
energy and time it's not just an apology
we're calling for
i think i hope people realize it's
the call to deal with this a call for
change and action to right wrongs past
and present as the relationship between
the crown and canada's indigenous people
moves forward
abigail beeman global news ottawa
[Music]
over the span of her reign the queen has
outlived or outlasted a multitude of
world leaders when she was crowned 70
years ago winston churchill harry truman
joseph stalin and louis saint laurent
were in power she's endured through 14
british prime ministers 12 canadian
prime ministers and some 170
commonwealth leaders
[Music]
welcome back to london
the queen is one of the most
recognizable people in the world despite
decades in the public eye though she's
remained largely inscrutable i spoke
with robert hardman who has covered the
royals for years and just wrote a
biography called queen of our times
70 years is an awfully long time for
anyone to be in any role
what do you think is the significance of
this moment it's just one of those
moments i think where certainly in this
country we we just sort of stand back
and realize that although we've taken
the queen pretty much for granted for
the best part of 70 years because she's
so reliable she's always there she
always turns up she always does what we
expect her to do
now is the time to realize actually
that's that is quite something that
she's done so i think for her it's a
sort of it's a great reflection on
on what she's achieved and it is
considerable i mean to
help the country and the institution
together all these years to to be
running a hereditary institution that's
as strong today as it was when she took
over i mean people will look and say oh
look at the monarchy in all sorts of
crises i mean it's always faced crises i
think others some people might take
issue with that look at the 90s i mean
that was a very very dark period much
worse than that i mean 92 she famously
talked it was her anna's herbalist but
it really marked the start of sort of
five year period
of uh of fractured marriages rouse over
money culminating of course in the
tragic death of diana when she was
perceived to be out of touch i mean
those were those were seriously um
not quite existential but i mean that
that was a a real crisis period for the
monarchy because it affected the direct
line of succession you know it caused
doubt on the queen's air and i guess we
kind of collectively
move past those things and think we look
at the latest crisis of course yeah we
do we're always looking at the here and
now think oh my goodness how is she
going to cope with this the harry and
meghan question harry megan andrew you
know these are they're called them
challenges rather than crises i mean
they're not they're not an immediate
threat to the the whole institution but
this is this is what she's been going
through all her reign how aware is she
of the changing times
of how
she needs to change with the times she's
very aware i mean she might not uh
show it because that's not the nature of
monarchy you don't just sort of suddenly
respond like a weather vein you you you
have to absorb
shifts in public opinion and you have to
respond to them and you have to accept
that the life isn't always going to be
the same i mean prince philip once said
to me you know i mean actually the the
the monarchies that have gone
the reason they went most of them wasn't
because of revolution or radicals it was
because the people around them just kept
them cocooned and wrapped in cotton
wouldn't let them change and you have to
you have to change and and you have to
do it um
[Music]
you have to evolve monarchy's a work in
progress it's got to move with the time
thank you so much okay
and that is global national for this
friday we'll leave you with some moments
from saint paul's cathedral today
[Music]
the queen was unable to attend her own
service of thanksgiving but her presence
was felt thanks for watching good night
from london
[Music]
you